hi there Steve Kaufman here again you
have my wife playing piano in the
background I want to talk a bit today
now about the power of listening stephen
krashen of course is very strong on
reading and reading is a tremendous way
to increase your vocabulary and it's
very good it's very good preparation
program for our educational system such
as it is
and for your future professional success
and in language learning it's very
important you acquire a lot of words
that way but but to me the most powerful
way of learning is listening and I
recently had a chance to rediscover them
because I had been reading some of the
material that I studied when I first
started learning Russian where I would
listen 10 20 30 times maybe read it once
or twice save words and phrases review
the words and phrases but mostly listen
over and over and over again and now I
find when I go back to that material and
I'm going back to it because I want to I
want to hone my skills on the grammar
now that I've got a lot of this evening
and some of the patterns of the grammar
are starting to feel natural and then
and so that certain cases is just I say
them naturally but some other cases I
don't so I want to spend some more time
on this so I go back and I read some of
my beginner texts and I mean I can hear
those phrases that I listen to many many
times three years ago and so I point
that out because a lot of people that
get started in the language they listen
they find it frustrating they can't
catch you know all of it and stuff don't
worry it's all going into your brain and
eventually you will find it easier and
easier to understand and what's more in
a year or two from now you'll be able to
go back there and once again mine that
content for words that you need for
patterns that you need for phrases that
you need
and it'll still be ringing in your mind
that's how powerful listening is and I'm
sure that there's good reason for this
first of all I do believe that
everything that goes into our head one
way or another is stored somewhere we
just can't retrieve it and I believe
that because we have been listening as
beings we have been listening for much
longer than we for reading I think
there's something much more visceral
about the listening than than the
reading and even now in my Russian
burning I listen I listen I listen I
listen for the patterns but that sticks
with me so by all means combine
listening and reading and certainly I
believe a review of words especially
right after you've read something or
listened to song is very effective but
listening all by itself is is an
extremely powerful way to learn and as
you mentioned you know with regard to my
wife who's playing piano in the
background
she started five years ago and we had
this conversation she said you know I'm
trying to learn this new piece it's
difficult I can't get it she said do you
find it frustrating when you can't get
things and she said because she said she
doesn't and I said no I don't because I
have that confidence that even though
I'm struggling to get something now if I
keep on doing it and in the case of
language I keep on listening and I keep
on reading and I keep on coming across
these words I will eventually get it I
have no doubt so that all the time that
I'm putting in I don't begrudge it I'm
not concerned I'm not on the timetable I
know that I will learn it and and it's
not me that decides the timetable and
it's not my teacher but I know that
we'll eventually get there and my wife
knows that she continues playing the
piece she's only gonna get better
he's not going to get worse and she's
not gonna plant tall so I guess what I'm
saying is listening is powerful believe
in it and believe that if you put in the
time with the language you will get
better so that's all I had to say there
I'm listening thank you